це має бути чітко прописано в законі
ніяких та інших тому що далі можна що
завгодно туди запхати в цей Реєстр і
будь-які Дані збирати Друзі Ну це буде
Big Brother Watches you Большой Брат за
тобою спостерігає Ну це треба зупиняти
не треба робити такі закони мета яких
незрозуміла це вже не для того щоб
полегшити облік військовозобов'язаних це
для того щоб знати про людину все все
Нащо це робити Давайте зупинимося і
зробимо те що дійсно необхідно а не
будемо
робити те що абсолютно немає жодного
значення повторю ще раз наше гасло зараз
має бути демобілізація заміна військових
оце ми маємо займатися а не такими
правками